[Music]
foreign
11th time South Florida will welcome the
Super Bowl back to Miami in 2020.
needless to say this will bring a whole
lot of people here to South Florida
[Applause]
[Music]
are you attending yeah you're going to
the Super Bowl yeah we've got the Super
Bowl on Sunday so we know a lot of
people are going to want to party so we
know the Smugglers are gonna want to get
in a piece of that
to your passports where are you going
today
we're looking for Narcotics and illegal
activities such as human trafficking and
prostitution and you live here I live in
Boston in Boston
we're trying to have our community safe
so let's get to work
we're at our arrival gate or flight
coming from in Colombia we brought a
virtual officers out here we're gonna
interview as many people as we can
euros
foreign
she may be tied to people that are
dealing narcotics or sometimes that
organization also profits off of
prostitution
[Music]
foreign
drugs ecstasy Coke and ketamine and the
new drug that's coming out now is called
tusi it's very popular now
right now we're just gonna see it's
narcotics wise she has anything on her
and uh we'll go from there
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
all right tonight I've been doing a
control delivery uh basically we're
contacted by HSI mobile they intercepted
a truck battery the truck battery was
smuggled across the Southwest border and
then it was going to head up this way
into Atlanta
the driver he admitted that he was
transporting narcotics in a hollowed out
battery didn't know what kind of
Narcotics he was carrying but agreed to
cooperate with us
they're going to contact their source
and source to hopefully drive out here
and take custody of the battery once we
get a little bit away from the meat
location we're going to apprehend
whoever's in the vehicle at the time we
don't know who's coming so just be alert
watch for counter surveillance and uh
you know just anything that's out of the
ordinary
all right let's take a look at the
battery
in Mexico they have plants that just
make these batteries specifically to
transport narcotics
heroin coke meth anybody got any
alligator clips put on this thing see if
it's hot
let's see if it Sparks what they'll do
is they'll hollow out the cells inside
the battery and they put a huge metal
plate at the bottom of the battery
because batteries are heavy so they
don't want them to feel light so it
works from that they'll go ahead and put
a motorcycle battery in there so if
somebody comes out there and checks the
battery they'll still get 12 volts and
think it's normal
we don't know what's in the battery
there's really no way of us finding out
without tearing the battery up because
everything's sealed tight like it's
factory made so that's just something
we'll have to find out later all right
that's it okay
the cooperator has the battery in his
truck and he's going to try to bring it
to the predetermined location our plan
is to set up around this local business
hopefully we'll see an exchange between
two vehicles a guy comes up picks up the
battery
but we just received this information
six hours ago we have no clue at all
who's picking up anything which is the
scariest part of this job because we
don't know their criminal history we
don't know if they're bringing guns to
the meat but that's what our group does
best is we we rally up when we need to
make sure everybody does everything
right make sure everybody goes home
right now we're just hanging into her
bags to see if she has any narcotics on
her
foreign
wow
make it out
um
he's testing a few little bottles to see
if they're tested positive for any type
of narcotic
[Music]
Circle
it was negative so I'm satisfied with
the bag
narcotics wise we didn't find anything
but she was a subject of interest and
the guy she's linked to sometimes leans
to prostitution
so that might be the other Avenue we're
digging into to see if maybe she's
coming for that
maybe he's running narcotics and girls
we just got one yeah
operation Renegade is a effort here at
the airport to identify foreign
Travelers that are seeking to engage in
the illicit sex industry and the deeming
that it is Super Bowl weekend we're
getting a lot of girls that are coming
to work
so we're gonna ask her further questions
if it turns out to be nothing so be it
but if it does I hope we get some good
Intel to disrupt these human trafficking
and prostitution organizations
foreign
[Music]
this is the parking lot where the
transaction supposed to occur
where the cooperator is going to meet
with the source
said we're going to spread out through
the parking lot and some other local
businesses in the area
all together we've got somewhere around
20 agents doing this control delivery
this evening
around the Dollar Tree
I wonder if we can park over here and
get a long eye
I don't want to get too long
all right the white Dodge Mark directly
in front of Dollar Tree about two rows
out
foreign
ER was instructed where to park in the
parking lot here the truck has arrived
and is standing by now waiting for the
unknown source here in Atlanta to meet
with them
just keeping his headlights on
I'm guessing he's doing that so
whoever's coming can
figure out where he is
a vehicle pulling up to the truck
passed on by
this store has blue lights flashing oh
they got a uniform car sitting there
the cops are probably inside for a shot
looking or something
if the person who's supposed to pick up
the battery sees lights it may spook
them and then they won't show up
foreign
car sitting there
the cops are probably inside for a shot
looking or something
[Music]
hey guys bad guys are a hard no they
will not come out tonight
they want to meet early in the morning
I can guarantee you that the bad guys
just got spooked by the police activity
in the area we're going to come back in
the morning probably pretty early and
get things started again
you know unfortunately we're on Doper
time and sometimes it goes fast
sometimes it doesn't and it's going to
go it's just going to go tomorrow
[Music]
foreign
approximately a year ago we used camera
footage of CCTV to identify a possible
career that came in pretty clear from
the Bahamas
he did not have to pass through customs
he did not have a check-in bag
he went down to the baggage carousel
took a bag off
and then got into ataxia
through our follow-up investigation
we've confirmed the bag was loaded with
kilos of cocaine
so it is our belief that there is an
internal conspiracy at the airport in
Nassau Bahamas
the drugs are being introduced by a
person that works at the airport
that bag with cocaine then flies to New
York's JFK Airport
then it's coming down the domestic side
here where the Karu is taking it away
and then the drugs have handed off to
the local distributor
this is a picture of ataru from last
year uh he's pretty distinguishable with
his striped shirt because it's like a
bumblebee we called him the Busy Bee
this is the first time he's coming back
to New York since then and only staying
until Saturday so we believe he's
smuggling cocaine again today
we're gonna try and catch some bad guys
tonight
we're gonna do surveillance
everybody's gonna be in plain clothes
right but have some sort of police
mocking we'll follow him till he gets to
the baggage carousel we'll see if he
picks up the suitcase and at that point
we'll hit him before he gets that
elevator for the taxi all right counter
surveillance be on the lookout for it
we're gonna get moving
she seems too clean for Comfort maybe
she's new to the game
they're testing her out first
we share for Super Bowl weekend so I
don't want to sound rude but she looks
kind of young maybe someone's sick
fantasy it's messed up but it's true
we know that some of the vulnerable
females from South America get picked up
by the cartels and they sometimes are
forced into prostitution so in this case
we're trying to make sure that she's
safe and trying to see exactly what's
going on
English
[Music]
hey
she's from here
so yeah Asia okay yeah
with your heart so I'm starting
Instagram
I found a social media account where she
seemed to have taken a lot of iron type
professional photos
she takes trips around the world
she has a very uh Prestige group of
friends that have money
she travels a lot for a teacher those
trips are paid for because teachers
don't make that much in Colombia
we're trying to verify how she's able to
afford all this travel if she can
explain that it will help us verify her
story
who bought your ticket for this trip
okay
[Music]
[Music]
foreign yes
do you have a picture
supposedly she was a backup singer for
an international Performing Artist so
we're just going to try to verify that
information she has pictures with him
he's also into modeling
so we dug a little deeper and we were
able to verify that she was indeed a
backup singer but she also does a lot of
modeling and she's also done some acting
it explains why her travel expenses are
usually covered by other people so she's
good to go
today
even though Our Last Passenger ended up
being a legitimate traveler we can't let
our guard down
while these sex trade organizations
continue to plague our society see VPP
would stay vigilant 24 7.
we were waiting for Lowe's to come in on
a flight from the Bahamas we have
approximately 26 people out here working
this up we're gonna have one CBP officer
with one HSI agent we're going to have
the NYPD Port Authority spread out
we're trying to cover every in and out
of exit every possible scenario
hopefully we're going to take the guy
down and affect the arrest
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we had to surveillance in place it was
great we made the rest everything went
pretty smooth hopefully the guys loaded
we seized the drugs and then we'll take
down this transnational criminal
organization
foreign
[Music]
anyway
okay Venezuela it's a Transit point with
nakati's coming to the country we're
trying to stop that
Trends
oh okay
so we're looking for Behavior body
language anything that seems other than
normal
we just saw this guy he was a little
fidgety trying to avoid our eye contact
so at this time I wanted to take him a
little bit more check his back and see
what's up
regalos
foreign
okay
[Music]
foreign
I think
yeah it's scheduled four he has a
prescription he's visiting no he's from
here
it's like maybe a month supply
can you let it go yeah you can let it in
okay
this is just one we missed but we're
just gonna keep going just get the next
one
okay
the problem is worse now we got a girl
there all I've been told was a female
um that she was possibly loading so
we're gonna go see
I'm gonna go the same spot we're set up
to meet at last night and the cooperator
will make the transaction with the
source
the place over here with his Dollar
General plenty of groups of cars to
blend into
I got eyes on the cooperator
just in the parking lot
the cooperator has arrived
The Source here in Atlanta gave us a
description of the car he'll be arriving
in
we got the target vehicle and play he's
coming in the parking lot right now
that little hatchback yeah
it's not an SUV it's not a van it's a
hybrid thing
the target car is rolling around in the
Walmart parking lot
yeah Cooperators stand out of his truck
right now
put up and he's swollen on the back of
the truck
all right bad guys moving in that
direction
he's pulling up on the driver's side of
the cooperator's truck
watch out kids there's drug trafficking
going on
yeah Cooperators staying out of his
truck right now
all right the driver of the truck
retrieved the battery and is taking it
over to the gold Toyota and looks like
he might be putting it in the back seat
all right package is in the Toyota
gold Toyota is pulling off
Madison's right indicator
he's right here next to us
you got ahead of us
about to make a right
and we're at the uh red lights he's
number one in the lane to turn left
we have a trooper standing by to assist
us with a traffic stop and then from
there we'll conduct the investigation to
find out what type of narcotic is
actually in the battery
okay let's let this guy go a little ways
and definitely not out of Douglas County
we'll get him on the interstate I
imagine
came from the Bahamas he wasn't supposed
to have a bag he came out was it a
baggage carousel and picked up a large
Blue duffel bag which we believe was not
checked in now we're gonna search see
what we find
yeah all the way to the bottom
the side of the bags pull the zipper
open
what do you got just close
just keep pulling
nothing
yeah there's nothing there
we found nothing in it
but we're going to continue to gather
evidence we're gonna check your body
searches person and we'll see what
happens from there
they should go
we're gonna check your body
[Music]
done
what do you got okay
research this person and one of the AIDS
discovered that he had pellets hidden in
his roaring area
so we're going to test what type of drug
it is
positive for cocaine
did you get the weight
260 on the nose
roughly a quarter kilo probably ten
thousand dollars
right now we're processing the defendant
the defendant is being charged with
conspiracy to import a controlled
substance
the way these pellets are they're pretty
consistent with people that swallow
pellets
so we're going to get an x-ray on this
guy because not only are we concerned
about more drugs but we're concerned
about his safety a hell of burst you're
pretty much dead you can get over those
in a second
foreign
[Music]
we have a girl that's coming from
Amsterdam she is traveling for five days
she came back with different containers
creams shampoos lotion there's about
four five six months
the thing is there's no scent of that
shampoo right
nobody travels with six seven bottles of
shampoo
you test that already I'm gonna take a
good look
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
okay awesome
interesting Academy
is a street drug that they're using as
precursors to cut into 2cb which is a
popular club drug right now testing all
these yeah
positive Academy yeah
we're looking at about six Keys Academy
we have Super Bowl week going on so it's
big money it's a big Market out there
for Academy especially here in Miami so
it's a really good stop that the
officers made
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I got an eyeball on the driver of the
gold car
foreign
[Music]
is we'll follow the vehicle and once
we're far enough away uniform Patrol
will go ahead and stop the car
so you see him he's right up next to
that tractor trailer
with these traffic stops the Troopers go
up and they talk to the guy but you
don't know if he's armed you don't know
if he's got other drugs or other
instruments in the car that could harm
the Troopers so something could happen
the dangers are still there
oh definitely he's riding that truck's
bumper
it's against the law in Georgia to
follow too close
we gotta move
hey if y'all can get over the trooper's
coming up right now
all right
here we go
blue lights wrong
yeah I'm stopped on the side of the road
I'll be behind the Troopers
state troopers were able to get uh
traffic violation following too closely
on the target vehicle
[Music]
copy
so we just found out the driver of the
vehicle does not have a driver's license
while operating the vehicle in the
public roadway
the driver is going to be arrested here
momentarily
since this person has no driver's
license we're going to impound the
vehicle take it back to the local
jurisdiction Sheriff's Office search the
vehicle take custody the battery and do
a further investigation to determine
what type of illegal narcotics in the
battery
fans want to get Super Bowl gear but
fake NFL gear has Federal authorities
cracking down
[Music]
got it
okay
Super Bowl is going to be hosted this
year in Miami and we expect a lot of
counterfeit items are going to be sold
so today the operation is focusing on
counterfeit products specifically NFL
products
what is that look we got one there that
looks like textiles stop it let's take a
look at that
we got that one and this other one
here we got one Jersey here
there we go
more jerseys probably close to 100 some
of them are just thrown in but if they
were authentic the packaging would be a
whole lot better they're cheap the
material is not going to be as flim csds
are let's see what we got on this box
looks like some hats I see a lot of
different teams there though
you have bills Titans so it's not just
the two teams that are going to Super
Bowl it's not just the 49ers and the
Chiefs you know San Francisco
Kansas City typical counterfeiter they
just counterfeit a whole bunch of
products and they stick it together in
one large box look at the colors on
these the poor quality you get one
legitimate product if you were to put it
face to face you will see aspects that
are different
you might purchase authentic hats for 35
dollars some of them go as expensive as
forty dollars you know your typical NFL
jersey 175 180 bucks whoever buys these
things thinking that there are
legitimate items they're being robbed
that's a good little find right there
hold on we got something there yeah we
might want to look at that one right
there look like it had a metal inside of
it
let's see what we got on this box
here we go
NFL Super Bowl championship rings
yep we got more of the same thing Super
Bowl rings from like years past and it
just has like misspellings we found one
of the Rings that instead of saying
Super Bowl said gooper Bowl off with a G
these things actually have a high value
that's a good find right there
we're gonna detain the shipment we're
gonna seize it we took a counterfeit off
the street you know things like that is
what gets you proud of the job that you
do
we're gonna go
we got the car back we're doing an
inventory search on the vehicle right
now
trying to make sure it's no weather
building our cars in the car or Firearms
money and things along those lines
we good
due to the unknown substance inside the
battery and some type of sealant wrapped
around we're not going to open ourselves
so for our protection we have fire
department Hazmat come out and respond
and open up the battery for us to find
out what substance is inside
yes 100 percent
so that's a portable x-rated device and
it'll show for any voids or any
anomalies such as packages or something
like that
it didn't reveal a whole lot which means
it's probably packed pretty tightly in
there
my belief would be cocaine or heroin in
the battery it could be fentanyl uh we
don't know
fentanyl is one of the most dangerous
substances out there right now
any type of exposure to it can be
life-threatening
so therefore we're gonna have an open
air area to open up the battery to keep
any exposures down
[Music]
thank you
excellent job
we hammered into it real quick and some
grayish chalky substance came out you
want to get a test kit yeah
[Music]
and it's green
that's positive for heroin
we went ahead and tested and tested
positive for heroin but they're going to
go ahead and peel the plastic sides off
to reveal the kilos that are in there
and then try to methodically pull those
out so that we don't damage the kilos
anymore than they were on the first hit
I mean you can feel it
a metal plate on the bottom and a metal
plate on the side that's to give it the
weight it's nice yeah I feel like a real
battery
somebody's just transporting a battery
you're not going to think that it's got
anything bad in it
but these specifically are made to
conceal illegal narcotics
in this instance it was smuggled across
we really don't know how it could have
come across in a plane to Texas and then
a car picks that one battery out of 20
that were on the airplane up throws it
in the back of a car or a truck and
drives it out to Atlanta five
once you're done get them to hose this
off
today's investigation was successful we
prevented five keys of heroin from
getting into the streets and communities
of the city of Atlanta
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
multiple pellets of cocaine that were
concealed on his person consistent with
someone that might swallow pellets of
cocaine
all right I'm ready
we don't know that this guy's loaded but
he had 250 grams which seems like a
really small weight to me to travel all
the way here
all right so now we're going to see if
the X-ray is positive or negative
foreign
they confirmed that it was negative so
there's no presence of any foreign
bodies within the intestine we can get
them out of here oh God I'm gonna walk
back to that room where we just were
okay
he admitted to the previous drug trip
and he says he's not really sure what
happened on this trip because the drugs
didn't come in the suitcase but they
were supposed to
it's been a long day most of us started
at least 12 hours ago and it's been some
twists and turns along the way but you
know we got our guy so overall win
foreign
it is a disappointing night for Niners
fans in the end it's the Chiefs who are
taking home the Vince Lombardi Trophy
[Applause]
it's been an exciting few weeks here in
Miami as the region opens its doors to
football fans from around the world for
Super Bowl 54
. between last year's game and this
year's games we have collectively skis
over 176 thousand counterfeit items with
a value of more than 120 million dollars
in addition to these seizures law
enforcement officers have made criminal
arrests in relation on human trafficking
forced labor identity theft drug
smuggling just to name a few
our success heavily relies upon building
effective Partnerships with HSI special
agents
cep officers and state and local police
departments around the country
so these record-breaking numbers affirm
law enforcement's commitment to
protecting the health and safety of
American consumers the economy the
legitimate businesses from criminals
excluding fan enthusiasm here at Super
Bowl 54.
foreign
[Music]